[Música]
sirenas de alertas sonaron en las calles
de seúl al tiempo que los canales de
noticias surcoreanos interrumpieron sus
programas
[Música]
nos acaba de llegar esta noticia el
Estado Mayor declaró que Corea del Norte
ha lanzado un vehículo espacial hacia el
sur la alerta duró poco el misil se
estrelló en el mar Amarillo minutos
después de su lanzamiento Correa del sur
publicó estas fotos de los restos
encontrados en un comunicado las
autoridades norcoreanas explicaron el
fallo por una inestabilidad del motor y
del suministro de combustible John John
no había advertido el martes del
lanzamiento de este satélite espía
destinado según sus autoridades a
contrarrestar la acción militar
estadounidense Japón por su parte lo
consideró como un lanzamiento de misil
balístico encubierto Y puso a las
fuerzas de defensa en alerta desplegando
sus sistemas antimisiles
con estos repetidos lanzamientos de
misiles Corea del Norte sigue amenazando
la seguridad de nuestro país de la
región y de la comunidad internacional
estos lanzamientos de misiles violan las
resoluciones del Consejo de Seguridad de
la ONU pero
norcoreanas no tienen intención de
detenerse anunciaron que procederán con
un nuevo lanzamiento a más tardar el 11
de junio